so I want to thank you guys for this
movie mostly because it reminds me why I
am never going in the ocean again yeah
straight up Oh the oceans amazing no
it's not every movie that Hollywood puts
out lets me know I should not go in this
water go in there uh-huh
so can you actually are you guys like
swimmers can you actually go in the
water you're not like double-checking
everything I love the water it's
terrifying
and you don't be like beer you should be
wary the water doesn't give a [ __ ] right
but number one in tried-and-true waters
I like my swimming pool that's that no
no that annoys me when people go and
stay in a hotel on the beach and then
they swim in the swimming pools I'm like
the beach is right there it doesn't seem
like waste it does seem like it's crazy
I've actually seen a lot of people doing
that oh that's but also you can make the
argument that that is because of
Hollywood movies telling us what's in
the water how many people actually
suffer creature bites or stings in the
water you know I mean arguably a lot of
people it could just be you know
Hollywood movies every shock is out to
get you yeah you know no listen I this
is what I believed in
I mean I've kind of let me let me get
off this [ __ ] joke um no stay on the
joke no keep going let me drive it into
the ground
nope um ah I was actually watching when
I was watching the movie though I was
like this had to have been a effin
brutal shoot those costumes look like
they weighed a ton
was it just like a huge pain in the ass
to shoot or was it like and still a lot
of fun it was a lot of fun cuz the cast
was a lot of fun cuz the cost but I
would say it was maybe not a huge pain
to shoot a large pain a lot of pain
yeah it's physically in a large pan yeah
it really does like uncomfortable which
is challenging is really really
challenging which is part of kind of the
appeal I guess yeah
like wow you never read scripts like
this before
yeah I did appreciate that it just jumps
right on in yeah yeah
there's no okay yeah there's no
expositional back straight it just goes
boom you're there it happens when it is
100% I because I've not much time left I
want to ask each of you an individual
question I could not be more excited for
the Matrix movie or the new Jurassic
have you guys I have to ask have you
read a script and what was your reaction
like loved the script actually she kept
like I loved the Jurassic script yeah no
Mamadou gave me the script and I
photocopied it and i actually have
copies for all my family and friends the
best Christmas game I did not give the
script to that woman are you like
buttoned is she even in it am I even
here my real passive she is this the
matrix make up in the matrix right now
dude I'll leave it there and just say I
am very excited I did hear it starts
shooting pretty soon and I'm over the
moon and your movie starts shooting soon
too we're trying to keep these jobs dude
I gotta go Congrats on this great to see
you both